a message of peace at a time of
political turmoil mothers joined hands
after a violent incident between
supporters of rival political parties
brought back dark memories inal Romani
was where Lebanon Civil War began in
1975 they called for national unity the
people that are fighting now are born
after 1980 after the war the war was
gone they don't know what is the taste
of the of the world they don't know if
if blood will come blood will doubt they
will not give them food to to eat it
will not give them job opportunities
they walked from the mainly Christian
neighborhood of ina Romani towards what
was the frontline that divided the
Lebanese capital they then crossed into
the mainly Shia neighborhood of XI air
it was a warm welcome from neighbors who
seemed to want to leave the past behind
but it was a different picture a few
nights ago there was a standoff between
supporters of Christian opposition
parties and backers of Shia parties in
power Amal and Hezbollah who have used
force against anti-establishment
protesters across the country in recent
days the establishment is doing what
they best do is just play on the
sectarian the sectarian emotions they're
trying to use the tools on the street of
intimidating peaceful protesters and
this is being used basically to I think
for internal kind of balance and power
struggle in between their establishment
parties opposition parties have been
accused of hijacking a popular uprising
for almost two months there have been
protests against the political elite who
are refusing to give up power
[Applause]
and stability that is why many are
concerned the longer this political
crisis lasts and the longer people
remain in the streets the likelihood of
more violence increases senator al
jazeera
Beirut